Is there any remedy for bone marrow injury where you don't make v-cells anymore due to drug toxicity of chemotherapy and retuximate?
Right now, I have to, and I have to go in for IV, infusions of gavocomulins to replace my old, immune system.
I don't want to do this the rest of my life.
Yeah, that's, it is very hard. You're trying to re-dute tissue and there is, there's some nutrition that you could do to help with bone marrow production.
I have to think about that a bit. I want to say I don't have that on the top of my head.
Again, I'm probably going to schedule a case review with me because we can look at a nutritional approach for this.
But it's just going to be supporting that and I presume you're getting these measured when you go in.
So you could test and see whether a nutritional approach would help.
But it is the, it is part of the danger of doing chemotherapy and you damage other tissue.
And the most susceptible to damage are tissue that is highly metabolic, cell lines that are highly metabolic.
That's your, your immune system is a cell line that's highly, highly metabolic and your hair follicles are highly metabolic.
That's why when people go into the chemotherapy, they lose their hair because it's your chemotherapy is going to have predilection towards higher metabolic cell lines.
Which is good because that's what cancer is and we want it to attack the cancer, but it also attacks those other cell lines.
So it could really damage our immune system response and that's why when you go in for chemotherapy.
Infusions, they have to test your white blood cell code because typically you have a diminished white blood cell code because you have a diminished ability to make white blood cells.